sur les dossiers qui ne font pas grief
donc c'est tout ce qui est notation de
5-plus est supérieure avec une
homogénéité des documents qui sont
demandés
effectivement je crois qu'on est tous
d'accord pour dire qu'un prévisionnel de
trésorerie à 12 mois n'a pas de sens
aujourd'hui
a fortiori s'agissant d'un commerce qui
est fermé ce point est aujourd'hui clair
entre nous et les banques
il faut prendre en compte le fait que
les banques partent d'un référentiel
classique d'instruction de dossiers et
doivent faire face à un nouveau
référentiel qui avec une garantie d'état
et avec des questions qui ne répondent
pas ce qu'elle pose celle qu'elle pose
d'habitude il est possible de demander
la notation de la banque de france
lorsqu'on n'en disposent pas il est
évidemment possible de faire appel à la
médiation du crédit est effectivement
nous notre dispositif de sécurité c'est
le foot est ce parce que lorsque vous
êtes engagé par une garantie d'état à
100% ça revient à faire un crédit direct
de la part de l'état à l'entreprise
on a un système qui a fait sont la
preuve de son efficacité c'est le
vitesse est qui et qui pourra être
utilisée sur l'ensemble du territoire je
voudrais préciser une chose sur le
dispositif de garantie 100 % pour
l'allemagne
il est réservé aux entreprises qui sont
bénéficiaires depuis trois ans donc ça
correspond pas vraiment un dispositif
orientée vers les entreprises en
difficulté c'est peut-être la nuance
qu'il faut avoir en tête sur le fond de
solidarité
nous avons effectivement pris en compte
assez largement beaucoup de thématiques
d'élargissement la prochaine étape ce
sera clairement de faire un
un dispositif ou des dispositifs
orienter le président de la république
l'a annoncé dans son allocution de lundi
orienté sur le tourisme la culture
l'événementiel l'hôtellerie restauration
et les pistes qui sont examinées c'est
notamment un élargissement de cette
approche à des à des entreprises dans la
taille serait un peu supérieures à
celles que nous retenons aujourd'hui
comme très petites entreprises donc
moins d'un million de chiffre d'affaires
moins de 10 salariés pour avoir une
réponse opérationnelle et concrète pour
ces entreprises particulières sur le
chômage partiel je voudrais juste
compléter sur un point pour avoir eu à
traiter aussi ces dossiers avec muriel
qu il bénit qu il est clair que les
demandes de chômage partiel de grandes
entreprises sont examinés directement
directement par le cabinet de la
ministre et par la ministre elle-même
qui va poser des questions sur mais
pourquoi donc 40 % de personnes en
chômage partiel à qui cela
correspond-t-il quelle est la part de
fonctions support quelle est la part de
fonction dans les boutiques et c'est
donc ce n'est pas un chèque en blanc qui
est fait aux entreprises
il faut également avoir en tête
s'agissant des entreprises qui sont dans
le domaine du conseil en réalité toutes
les prestations ont été arrêtés d'eau
qu'elles sont elles mêmes confrontés à
des situations pour une partie d'entre
elles de chiffre d'affaires 06 et du
commissariat aux comptes c'est plus
inquiétant parce que théoriquement c'est
un peu le moment où elles doivent sortir
les comptes et il ya un certain nombre
de d'entreprises qui en ont besoin
d'avoir de la visibilité sur sur leur
compte en tout état de cause comme l'a
très bien dit monsieur le ministre il ya
des contrôles et il y aura des contrôles
merci beaucoup
alors mes chers collègues à moi que
vivier n'ya pas vraiment de questions du
donc nous allons débuter la longue série
de questionnements de mes collègues on
va évidemment les regrouper parce que
j'en remets ma menant 16 donc ça va être
très compliqué donc
il attire vraiment l'attention de chacun
sur la responsabilité à être concis
jérôme bascher pour commencer suivi
d'éric moquer jérôme un oui monsieur le
président un spécialiste remercie vous
poser une question sur les crimes
justement pour olivier dussopt
parce que je n'ai pas tout compris dans
l'histoire des 500 2500 euros pour les
colis de drogue ont été soumis au pavot
covic 19 parce qu'aujourd'hui quelques
régions serbes ont été eux fut mise mais
devint peut-être que toutes les régions
pays très bien sans danger pas forcément
repris cette nuance mais au-delà de
cette prime
je n'ai pas compris non plus la
philosophie qui est justifié les
passages pour lui et sa déprime ou pour
les fonctionnaires d'état a des tripes
ou de collectivités locales je pense que
chacun doit prendre son effort il ya un
sujet particulier des soignants et on
comprend bien
je suis totalement d'accord sur le bfr
les montants et l'esprit la philosophie
de mer général mais cette partie la
découverte un peu au débotté là
l'histoire président de la république me
laisse un peu pantois
merci merci merci jérôme éric bocquet
puis arnaud bazin éric bocquet
oui bon ton et anti gouttes eric
messieurs les ministres mesdames les
listes alors ma question portera
davantage sur un cadre un peu plus large
que celui strictement parlant du plfr on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir en
commission et en séance la semaine
prochaine dans ma question porte
davantage sur le cadre européen et
notamment le rôle de la bce ou que la
bce mon avis pourrait avoir dans cette
situation extrêmement grave
on voit bien que les cif qui sortent
depuis quelques temps sur les baisses
annoncées du pib sont loin d'être d'être
stabilisée déficit a explosé c'est une
évidence
et est ce que la gravité de la situation
à mon avis n'imposerait pas des mesures
tout à fait exceptionnel les mesures non
conventionnelles au niveau de la bce
est-ce qu'on n'a pas raté le coche à
bruxelles la semaine dernière est-ce
qu'on n'est pas encore encore
dans les l'orthodoxie monétaire cher à
nos partenaires je pense à l'allemagne
je pense aux pays bas au luxembourg à
l'autriche par exemple et je veux mettre
en contrepoint le l'exemple de ce qui
s'est passé au royaume uni avec la
banque centrale britannique qui va
financer directement le trésor dans
cette crise afin de m'aider à affronter
les ravages sanitaires économiques
donc c'est quand même un sacré tabou qui
vient de tomber avec cette décision
un tabou de la doxa libérale que l'on
connaît à savoir l'indépendance des
banques centrales et l'interdiction qui
leur est faite de financer directement
les états le gouverneur de la banque
d'angleterre avait étonné ce propos
conforme à la doxa le 6 avril et trois
jours plus tard il annonce cette
décision selon laquelle la banque
d'angleterre va financer directement le
trésor britannique
la réserve fédérale américaine a pris la
décision analogue est ce qu'il ne serait
pas temps de redéfinir le rôle de la bce
dans cette crise dont on ne mesure pas
encore tout à fait à mon arrivée
aujourd'hui l'ampleur et la profondeur
dans les mois et les années qui viennent
merci merci eric arnaud bazin et roger
karoutchi
arnaud bazin but merci monsieur le
président madame messieurs les ministres
l'essentiel des mesures du premier pfr
visait certainement assurer le maintien
d'une trésorerie suffisante dans les
entreprises la d'exception des mesures
de chômage partiel pour celles qui ont
relevé les fonds de solidarité mais
certains secteurs d'activité sont
surtout inquiets pour leur compte
d'exploitation puisque sur leur
trésorerie et ce deuxième plfr nous
avoir à mon sens comme objectif de
resserrer le tamis de la raquette si on
ne pas perdre
ainsi le secteur du bâtiment où les
marges sont habituellement faible on
contre déçu roue lors de la reprise
d'activité difficulté renchérissement
d'approvisionnement impossibilité de
tenir les délais parce que productive
est liée aux précautions sanitaires en
matière de marchés publics une
ordonnance apporte des réponses
l'attention dont généraliser les
principaux marchés privés qui sont la
plus grande part de l'activité des
entreprises du bâtiment
d'autres petites entreprises présentent
la particularité de devoir conserver
leurs mandats
avec une production nul ou très limité
il ya beaucoup d'exemples citerai par
exemple 2 sur les des entreprises qui
travaillaient des animaux les centres
équestres ou les éleveurs de chiens là
il faut continuer à nourrir et
entretenir les animaux de plus discutés
plus au sénat en commission et ailleurs
j'entends bien est ce que vous pensez
vous que la maladie que l'état de la
france peuvent attendre les états d'âme
de tel de telle ou telle qu'elle n'y a
pas une situation exceptionnelle
une situation d'urgence que nous devons
adopter une loi ont besoin pour faire
face à un acompte d'un déconfinement qui
est compliquée mais qui est nécessaire
que on devrait avoir des algues des
susceptibilités de temps c'est une
situation exceptionnelle
certes le temps est contre un certes
qu'on n'avance pas de charge mais il
faut le faire
alors les élus locaux ils sont consultés
aujourd'hui il faut dire que le plan de
déconfinement pèse largement aussi sur
leurs épaules quels moyens
faut-il pour les collectivités pour
assumer une telle responsabilité
de nombreux maires disent déjà que pour
eux ils voient que ça va être très
difficile
quels moyens je ne comprends pas très
bien votre question sur les moyens cake
et la question des moyens d'imposer
collectivités disent qu'elles n'ont pas
forcément les moyens par exemple
d'équiper les personnels dans les écoles
avec les masques avec et bien tout où
tous les moyens qui vont être
nécessaires tenant plus de personnes par
exemple dans les écoles pour accueillir
des enfants en demi groupe pour faire
l'étude etc mais j'aimerais bien que
tous les élus qui se bat tous les ans
pour lutter contre les fermetures de
classes au moment où les matières on les
ouvre
c'est la même ouverture d'esprit pour
pouvoir le faire mais ça c'est un aparté
personnel que je veux dire bien sûr
c'est difficile pour tout le monde
c'est difficile pour l'état c'est
difficile pour les départements c'est
difficile pour les régions c'est
difficile pour les particuliers c'est
difficile pour tout le monde mais moi je
salue l'engagement des maires qui sont
très positifs ils ne sont pas dans la
récrimination ou dans les doléances
ils sont dans l'engagement positif et
ils veulent le faire le meilleur moyen
pour répondre à votre question
et bien c'est aujourd'hui de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une cohérence une
concertation territoriale et que ce
qu'on appelle ce que déjà certains
départements feu
face des comités départementaux de
déconfinement qui associe le préfet les
services de l'état l'état la région le
département les assemblées de mer les ep
six établissements de coopération
intercommunale et les parlementaires
faire des comités d confinement qui sont
capables ensemble de trouver les
solutions pour apporter aux élus les
moyens dont ils ont besoin pour assurer
ce déconfinement nécessaire est-ce que
vous jugez qu'il y a eu suffisamment
d'unités dans la prise de parole de
l'exécutif jusqu'ici bien sûr je pense à
tous ces échos qu'il y a eu et bien sûr
les dissensions qu'il y aurait eu entre
l'elysée et matignon moment je demande à
ce que je connais c'est cette idée de
dissension entre l'elysée et matignon
femme a été infirmée par les deux
parties je pense que c'est très je
trouve que ce débat politique aux
politiciens
au moment où nous affrontons une crise
où le gouvernement fait preuve de
courage à ceux ci l'ensemble des forts
de ce pays
à ceci le parlement il le fera encore
lundi d'aller chercher aujourd'hui
d'éventuelles polémiques entre l'elysée
et matignon de paraître de nature
indécente par ailleurs est choquant
un mot enfin sur rome eh bien les
intentions derrière ce déconfinement ont
par exemple on a largement entendu à
jean michel blanquer redire que le plus
important pour lui et bien c'était la
fracture sociale qu'il fallait pouvoir
résorber mais vous entendez bien tout ce
qu'ils disent
il y annonce que le sentiment que l'on a
c'est surtout et bien le le retour au
travail des parents que auquel pense le
gouvernement lorsqu'il pense aux
déconfinement des écoles et la preuve en
est que ce son est bien d'abord les
maternelles et les classes élémentaires
qui sont envisagées j'ai bien compris il
ne faisait pas vous et apparaît aussi
que sont les plus petits qui sont les
moins vulnérables
sauf événement qu'on a évoqué
aujourd'hui tout à l'heure
ovide nom magique à wazemmes il y a des
raisons d'abord de la réinsertion
sociale et scolaire des enfants qu'elle
nécessaire et surtout les tout petits
c'est nécessaire ensuite il y à bien sur
l'impératif aussi répartie dollar plus
de travail qui a tous les impératifs
dans cette affaire ne vous savez ceux
qui trouve aucune grâce à aucune des
mesures de déconfinement serais bien
incapable aujourd'hui de des confiner la
france et de l'amener par là à sa perte
donc moi je me remets tout ce que vous
avez vu l'opposition salué une des
mesures de confinement est la seule de
quelques-unes hier à l'assemblée parce
qu'elle était proposée aussi par par
rapport à l'est républicain
mais j'entends depuis dix jours toutes
les propositions des confinement qui
sont faites être systématiquement
détruites critique et analyser de façon
négative par l'opposition ça n'est pas
une façon constructive de faire repartir
notre pays est-ce que vous jugez vous
enfin que le parlement parvient à
fonctionner normalement
sur cette période un certain nombre de
sénateurs estiment qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à faire leur travail de contrôler
correctement
pour le coup il n'y a pas forcément
d'unanimité là-dessus certains jugent au
contraire que ils ont réussi à faire un
certain nombre d'auditions le
fonctionnement du parlement est il pour
vous satisfaisant écoutez à ce que j'en
juge par le nombre de réunions de
commissions écriture souvent très
longtemps par la présence personnelle
des groupes représentés par leurs
membres à la fois dans l'hémicycle et
dans les commissions aujourd'hui j'ai
pas le sentiment que le parlement soit à
l'arrêt il est peut être ce qui
aujourd'hui veulent par contre dès qu'on
file et qui voudraient très présents ici
il ya des contradictions
il ya des mécontentements qui veulent
s'opposent qui peuvent se faire dès
qu'ils sont des postures politiciennes
je trouve que le moment n'est pas la
posture politicienne il est plutôt au
travail en commun et bien merci à
beaucoup françois patriat d'avoir
répondu à mes questions françois patriat
merci président du groupe de la
république en marche
ici au sénat alors que vous entendez
bien cette cloche cette sonnerie qui
retentit et qui annoncera le début de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement après la séance qui a été
consacrée hier au débat sur le plan de
déconfinement à l'assemblée nationale la
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
ce matin à l'assemblée
elle ment à 11h et bien c'est maintenant
au tour donc des sénateurs de
questionner le gouvernement est bien au
sujet de ce plan de déconfinement
notamment vous le voyez est bien pour
l'instant gérard larcher qui devrait
présider la séance n'est pas encore
présent dans l'hémicycle à on attend que
le président du sénat arrive voilà il
est en train d'arriver on voit les
huissiers qui arrive alors je vous
rappelle donc l'ordre du jour de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et va y avoir une dizaine
de questions de tous les groupes
beaucoup sur le plan de déconfinement
mais aussi sur des sujets très divers
sur le tourisme la culture mais aussi
bien sûr sur cette question très
épineuse des masques du financement des
masques et y en aura-t-il pour tout le
monde et à quel prix seront ils
accessibles et puis bien sûr un nombre
de questions qui seront adressées à
jacqueline gourault sur le rôle des
collectivités notamment dans la sortie
de cette crise sanitaire voilà vous le
voyez à la cloche vient de sonner tout
de suite on prend la direction de
l'hémicycle du jeudi 23 avril a été
publié sur le site internet du sénat
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation il y
en a pas en séance
il est donc adopté
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
c'est avec tristesse que nous avons
appris la disparition de notre ancien
collègue henri weber
c'était le 26 avril dernier
cet universitaire s'était passionné pour
la politique depuis son adolescence
une jeunesse très engagé dans les
jeunesses communistes puis les
événements de mai 1968
il fut aussi cofondateur de la ville
communiste 1986 il rejoint le parti
socialiste dont il fut longtemps
secrétaire national
1988 henri weber devint conseiller
technique au cabinet de laurent fabius
alors président de l'assemblée nationale
puis de 1991 à 1993 il participa comme
chargé de mission kevin et de martin
malvy et du président louis mermaz il
était alors ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement
il fut maire adjoint de saint denis en
1989 puis conseiller municipal de thiais
pour seine maritime
en 1995 il fut d'ailleurs son entrée
cette même année dans notre assemblée
comme sénateur du département de la
seine maritime
au cours de ces neuf années de mandat
sénatorial henri weber membre de la
commission des affaires culturelles qui
revenait régulièrement dans les débats
concernant des secteurs qu'il
connaissait particulièrement
l'enseignement supérieur la culture ou
encore la communication et l'audiovisuel
parekh son bureau témoignait de son
érudition par le nombre de livres qui
l'occupé son engagement européen le
conduisit un siégé pendant dix ans au
parlement européen de 2004 à 2014 c'est
vrai qu'avec lui disparaît une figure
qui a marqué aussi notre vie politique
une personnalité dotée d'un sens de
l'humour
je m'en souviens ici personnellement un
intellectuel érudit et passionné par les
débats d'idées qui avait pour devise
d'agir en homme de pensée de penser en
homme d'action il avait acquis une forme
d'autorité intellectuelle il fut aussi
un combattant très déterminée contre le
racisme au nom du sénat joue les à la
fois rappeler sa mémoire lui qui a siégé
ici et j'en ai souvenirs et exprimer
notre sympathie à son épouse fabienne
servan-schreiber à ses enfants
ses proches à ceux qui ont partagé sa
vie dans le groupe socialistes et ceux
qui ont partagé ses engagements dans la
diversité de ce qu'ils ont représenté
par rapport à d'autres engagements dans
d'autres diversité je vous propose
d'avoir un moment de recueillement
je vous remercie
monsieur le premier ministre et dames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
notre ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
sous deux formats adaptés que nous avons
définies et la semaine passée notre
séance se déroule dans les conditions
respect des règles sanitaires mis en
place depuis le mois de mars rappelle
que l'hémicycle objets à chaque fois d'
un travail de désinfection avant et
après chaque séance
vous serez attentif à respecter les
distances de sécurité à respecter les
règles d'entrée sortie le gouvernement
sur le devant les sénateurs sur le
pourtour extérieur et je vous rappelle
que la science est retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et notre site internet
je donne la parole à notre collègue rémi
féraud pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues voilà donc le moment où
devons dire à la france comment notre
vie va reprendre ce sont vos mots
monsieur le premier ministre et il
témoigne de la gravité du moment
nous avons noté votre grande prudence
pour procéder un déconfinement sous
conditions par étapes et sur mesure
selon les territoires
nous sommes néanmoins très dubitatif sur
les modalités et les moyens mis en
oeuvre et à cet égard vous ne nous avez
pas convaincu trop d'ambiguïtés demeure
même la question de la fourniture de
masques à chaque français posée depuis
des semaines n'est toujours pas
entièrement réglée et le flou sur la
reprise de l'école inquiète les parents
les enseignants comme les maires les
principes qui guident vos décisions en
la matière ne sont d'ailleurs pas
claires et ne semble pas être ceux de la
réussite scolaire ni de l'égalité des
chances entre les enfants
quant à votre réponse à la crise sociale
dramatique qui est devant nous elle
n'est pas à notre avis à la hauteur de
la situation
nous sommes encore plus inquiet quand
nous entendons dès ce matin votre
ministre du travail
envisager de durcir les conditions du
chômage partiel au 1er juin ou votre
volonté de maintenir la réforme de
l'assurance chômage à la rentrée
après vous avoir écouté attentivement
hier je voudrais donc vous poser deux
questions quand et comment allez-vous
clarifier toutes les zones d'ombrés qui
demeurent encore et en particulier pour
l'école et allez vous enfin m l'urgence
sociale au coeur de votre politique face
à cette crise il pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez la parole monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur peut-être monsieur le président
avant de répondre à la question que
vient de me poser monsieur le sénateur
un mot pour dire que parce qu'il était
élu de seine maritime et parce que nous
avions des amis des amis communs j'avais
beaucoup d'estimé et d'affection pour
henri weber et que je m'associe aux
propos que vous venez de de tenir
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vous me posez la question de
l'esprit et de la méthode que nous
allons utiliser pour progressivement
sortir du confinement pour
progressivement faire repartir notre
pays
confiné qu'il est pour des raisons
sanitaires que vous connaissez
parfaitement les d'hier je le redis
aujourd'hui
et cet état d'esprit ne me quittera pas
nous devons être à la fois prudent et
résolu prudent parce que le
déconfinement entre guillemets est un
processus risquer et résolue parce que
ne pas des confiner le seraient au moins
tout autant
nous sommes donc condamnés d'une
certaine façon a avancé prudemment
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
indiqué hier dans mon propos que je
tenais à ce que les opérations de
déconfinement s'effectue progressivement
avec un pas de temps qui permet avant
qu'une nouvelle étape soit franchie de
vérifier que les mesures qui ont été
prises permettent
circonscrire l'évolution du virus
prudence transparence également d'air
pour dire effectivement quels sont les
résultats des mesures qui ont été prises
c'est le premier aspect le deuxième
aspect que j'évoquais hier c'est celui
d'une forme de différenciation de
territorialisation des mesures pour une
raison qui m'a paraît évidente et qui
j'en suis certain
l'est tout autant dans votre esprit nous
évoquer la question des écoles j'ai
indiqué hier qu'elle était la volonté du
gouvernement permettre la réouverture
progressive des écoles en commençant par
les pré élémentaire et les primaires
puis plus tard dans les zones où cela
est possible les collèges et on verra à
partir de début juin le 31 mai pour le 2
juin
ce qu'il en est s'agissant des lycées je
connais moins le moi je connais un petit
peu quand même le territoire dans lequel
vous avez été élu je connais bien le
territoire dans lequel j'ai été moins
bien mais lui je connais assez bien les
écoles de la ville dont j'ai été le
maire dans certaines écoles les
consignes que nous avons données
pourront être mises en oeuvre très
facilement parce que les locaux le taux
d'occupation de l'école les
investissements récents font que on
pourra utiliser la totalité des locaux
pour ne pas avoir des classes trop
complète jamais plus de 15 pour
permettre les mesures de distanciation
physique dans toute la mesure du
possible
bref pour que les choses s'organisent au
mieux dans d'autres ce sera plus
difficile
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
plaidé pour cette différenciation pour
faire en sorte que s'agissant des écoles
dans le cadre d'une doctrine général les
maires les directeurs d'école les
représentants de l'état puisse entamer
ce dialogue en confiance et trouver les
meilleures solutions pour que l'école
reprenne on peut ne pas être d'accord
monsieur le sénateur sur la nécessité
que l'école reprenne mais je vous le dit
tout de go
nous voulons que l'école reprenne nous
voulons que les enfants retrouvent le
chemin de l'école
et ensuite il nous faut trouver de
bonnes solutions pour que cela soit
possible en faisant évidemment
extrêmement attention à tous les aspects
liés à la sécurité sanitaire bien
entendu mais en faisant en sorte que ce
soit possible
il y aura donc une discussion locales
territoriales entre les acteurs de
terrain qui vont pouvoir conjuguer leurs
efforts pour faire en sorte que
l'objectif qui est fier d'en fixer dans
cette stratégie nationale puisse être
atteint alors vous me dites monsieur le
sénateur et du flou non y'a une doctrine
et ensuite il va avoir des applications
et si vous voulez me dit me faire dire
que je n'ai pas d'hier ou que je ne
dirais pas aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
détails applicable partout en france
vous avez raison je ne peux pas dire
l'ensemble de détail applicable partout
en france
je peux faire état d'une volonté
réouvrir les écoles je veux faire état
de principe
ils ont été fixés et en détails en
détail par le gouvernement des classes
de 15
plusieurs possibilités offertes sur ce
que pourront faire les élèves et ensuite
je vais faire confiance et au fond ça ne
devrait choquer personne aux directeurs
d'école au maire et au représentant de
l'état monsieur le sénateur
si vous pensez qu'il y à une autre
méthode une autre méthode pour battre
une épidémie que de faire confiance à
ceux qui sont au plus près du terrain
est capable de prendre des mesures
intelligentes
compte tenu des objectifs qu'on leur
fixe je vous assure monsieur le sénateur
je serais très heureux de l'apprendre je
serais très heureux de pouvoir en
discuter avec vous mais c'est la méthode
que nous avons retenu avec prudence avec
progressivité avec confiance le ferron
président jean temps la réponse nous
partageons la prudence face à la crise
sanitaire
il reste quand même très peu de temps
pour lever les ambiguïtés sur les
modalités de la reprise de l'école
adaptée au territoire et surtout vous ne
m'avez pas répondu sur l'urgence sociale
nous aimerions que sur ce point vous ne
soyez pas prudent mais vous soyez
résolus
je vous remercie merci la parole et l
autre collègue colette mélot pour le
groupe
les indépendants république et
territoires vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je voudrais avant tout saluer
cette date du 29 avril
il ya 75 ans les femmes étaient pour le
voter pour la première fois en france
monsieur le ministre
plus de vingt mille de nos compatriotes
ont été emportés par la pandémie de kovy
19 pour lutter contre le virus et pour
éviter qu'ils ne fassent davantage de
victimes
notre nation a fait bloc les soignants
en première ligne n'ont pas fléchi la
deuxième ligne a tenu bon et la grande
majorité de nos concitoyens a
scrupuleusement observé les mesures
barrières
cette unité se révèle précieuse dans le
combat contre la maladie
elle le sera tout autant lors du
déconfinement la coopération de toutes
les composantes de la société sera
essentiel pour assurer la remise en
marche de notre pays
des baisses considérables d'activité de
plusieurs administrations ont eu lieu
durant le confinement
c'est le cas de la justice aujourd'hui
quasiment à l'arrêt qui va devoir se
mobiliser fortement pour faire face à
d'importants retards
certaines entreprises chargées de
services publics comme la poste ont
également connu les difficultés
péniblement ressentie par les usagers
mais en ce moment en voie d'amélioration
nous avions également eu l'occasion
d'alerter le gouvernement sur la
nécessité de poursuivre la délivrance
des permis de construire afin de ne pas
mettre en péril la reprise des chantiers
aujourd'hui déconfinement sur ce point
nous avons été entendus
cependant nous continuons d'être
sollicité
et par des entrepreneurs dont l'activité
est suspendue par l'absence de décision
de l'administration
c'est notamment le cas des chantiers de
rénovation énergétique
les contrôles de qualité qui doivent
être relancées par l'administration pour
permettre leur financement via les
certificats d'économie d'énergie sont à
l'arrêt ce blocage bien réelle n'est
qu'un exemple parmi d'autres qui risque
d'entraver le redémarrage de notre
économie
les entreprises ont besoin de visibilité
et de flexibilité
monsieur le ministre vous pouvez vous
nous dire quelles mesures le
gouvernement at il prévu pour s'assurer
que la reprise l'activité administrative
pourra accompagner celle de nos
concitoyens pour vous répondre la parole
est secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
l'action publique et des comptes publics
monsieur du sobre vous avez la parole
monsieur lui nice merci merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice mélo vous
avez indiquée dans votre question que
certaines administrations ont dû
ralentir leurs activités pendant la
période de confinement c'est la réalité
du fait de la mise en oeuvre des plans
de continuité d'activité
au-delà des difficultés que vous avez
évoqué auquel nous avons apporté des
réponses souvent par bad ordonnance je
veux avant tout retenir le formidable
engagement
les agents publics dans cette période et
dans les trois versants agents publics
de la territoriale de l'hospitalière
bien sûr agents publics de l'état qui
ont fait face à la fois pour garantir la
mise en oeuvre des plans de continuité
d'activité de faire en sorte que les
fonctions essentielles des
administrations soient remplies tenue
agents qui se sont aussi investis par un
développement sans nulle comparaison du
télétravail puisque nous estimons pour
la fonction publique d'état canadien sur
quatre aujourd'hui et en télétravail
sert son administration à distance pour
garantir la continuité des services
nous l'avons fait avec les partenaires
sociaux chaque semaine j'échange avec
les neuf organisations syndicales avec
les directeurs des ressources humaines
des ministères avec les employeurs
territoriaux pour apporter
semaine après semaine des réponses et
garantir aussi la protection des agents
aujourd'hui il faut envisager la reprise
et il rebond de notre pays nous le
faisons avec le même souci du dialogue
j'étais encore ce matin avec les
organisations syndicales et les terras
je serai demain avec les employeurs
territoriaux pour apporter des solutions
parfois très techniques en matière de
titularisation et le maintien des
calendriers titularisation des décalages
des comptes
d'accès aux écoles de service public en
matière de normalisation dans la gestion
des trains de paix ou encore de
déplafonnement des comptes est pas mon
temps pour accompagner la reprise et
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
blocages
nous l'accompagnons aussi de manière
plus générale puisque l'ensemble des
ministères adieu formaliser des plans de
reprise d'activité plan de reprise
d'activité qui décrit comment
progressivement l'administration va
reprendre toute sa place
plan d'activité qui s'inscrivent
évidemment en cohérence et en
coordination avec l'intégralité des
orientations fixées par le premier
ministre devant l'assemblée hier
après-midi plan de reprise d'activité
dont nous assurons aussi la cohérence
d'un point de vue interministériel il
est essentiel que l'administration entre
sa place la fonction publique représente
un actif sur cinq
c'est à la fois une force de travail un
soutien et nous avons été pendant cette
crise l'importance de ce soutien pour la
continuité de la vie de la nation
demain nous verrons l'importance de son
soutien pour le rebond de tout notre
pays mais fuit la parole est maintenant
à madame catherine dumas pour le groupe
l'est républicain vous avez la parole
matière collègues
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
tout d'abord je voudrais aller dans le
sens de ma collègue colette mélot bien
entendu sur le droit de vote des femmes
et je peux pas m'empêcher de dire que
c'est aussi grâce à une ordonnance du
général de gaulle monsieur le premier
ministre
ma question s'adresse à vous si votre
propos hier a laissé entrevoir un
possible déconfinement pour de
nombreuses activités économiques certes
assorti de conditions qui mérite d'être
précisée l'horizon d'un retour à une
situation normale s'est éloigné pour les
festivals les salles de concert les
théâtres les cinémas
il en est de même pour les restaurants
les cafés les hôtels les campings les
parcs d'attraction les voyagistes
l'avenir pour eux reste vraiment très
incertain ces secteurs économiques sont
très largement composé d'un tissu de pme
d'indépendants et la crise sanitaire
alors a déjà mis un genou à terre une
vague de faillites et de disparitions et
malheureusement à craindre
rien que pour le tourisme c'est plus
d'un million de salariés concernés dans
notre pays 8 % de notre pib
les industries culturelles contre est
quant à elle contribue cette fois plus
au pib que l'automobile
alors monsieur le premier ministre lors
de la loi de finances rectificative vous
avez refusé la propos
ici on du sénat d'annuler les charges
qui pèsent sur ces entreprises préférant
maintenir un simple report de charge et
annonçant des discussions avec les
différentes parties avec vos propos
d'hier je ne doute pas que face au drame
qui s'annonce vous finissez par suivre
le sénat n'attendez pas monsieur le
premier ministre a annoncé ces mesures
dès maintenant les restaurateurs les
directeurs de théâtre et tous les autres
sont inquiets et pour eux le goût du
tunnel restent encore lointains très
lointain pour vous répondre la parole
est au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean-baptiste
lemoyne vous avez la parole les
sénateurs modem la sénatrice c'est clair
la situation est grave pour le secteur
du tourisme de la culture des sports
pour le tourisme on est à moins 100 %
quasiment d'activité et il est clair que
face à cette situation
et bien la réponse du gouvernement elle
a été rapide
elle a été massive d'une part avec
l'activité partielle qui a été utilisée
par la plupart des entreprises du
secteur avec les prêts garantis par
l'état nous en sommes à 4 7 milliards
d'euros pour le secteur du tourisme
c'est à dire que les acteurs se sont
emparés de cet outil et le président de
la république a été très clair il a
évoqué lors de son allocution du 13
avril l'annulation l'exonération de
charges pour les acteurs du secteur du
tourisme en particulier
il l'a réaffirmé vendredi dernier est
donc cette mesure elle va être mise en
place pour les mois de mars à juin est
par ailleurs au delà de cette période
comme le déconfinement est progressif et
que la reprise des activités
touristiques ou culturelles va être
progressive
il va falloir continuer d'accompagner
ses acteurs c'est pourquoi nous
préparons un certain nombre de mesures
d'accompagnement de soutien de relance
du secteur qui seront présentés lors du
comité international pour le tourisme
auxquels vous participez sous la
houlette du premier ministre ce sera le
14 mai prochain
j'étais à l'instant avec la caisse des
dépôts la banque des territoires la bpi
ou justement nous évoquons un certain
nombre de mesures de financement de
mesures
investissement de mesures d'ingénierie
et je peux vous dire que nous serons aux
côtés de ces acteurs du tourisme de ces
hôteliers de ces restaurateurs de celles
et ceux qui ont créé un certain nombre
de parcs historiques de loisirs tout
simplement parce que c'est parfois
l'héritage de génération qui se
transmettent à d'autres générations ce
sont des maisons où ce sont des des
créateurs et bien c'est très simple il
faut le rayonnement de la france
ils sont la france et nous serons
toujours à leurs côtés madame du bas
merci monsieur le ministre j'ai bien
noté votre réponse n'oubliez pas les
acteurs culturels même s'il relève pas
de votre portefeuille
il est notre devoir ici au sénat de
relayer la détresse de ces
professionnels qu'on empêche aujourd'hui
travailler et de leur apporter une lueur
d'espoir j'ajoute aussi comme élu de
paris j attache beaucoup d'importance
ges issues particulièrement sensible
alors que la mairie de paris à ce jour
ni accordent aucun intérêt merci
beaucoup
la parole est notre collègue jean marie
bockel pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
madame la garde des sceaux des annonces
du premier ministre hier à l'assemblée
nationale
on ne peut que se féliciter de la
confiance que le gouvernement accorde au
territoire pour mener au mieux le
déconfinement cela passe on en a
conscience aussi par la responsabilité
des collectivités territoriales dans un
nécessaire climat à la fois de
partenariat et de confiance entre elles
et l'état il reste néanmoins beaucoup de
points en suspens vous le savez je pense
particulièrement aujourd'hui à la
responsabilité personnelle y compris
pénale des employeurs dans le cadre du
défi finement alors que le travail doit
reprendre tous se mobilisent des
employeurs du privé y compris les pme du
monde associatif mais aussi des
employeurs du public et en particulier
les collectivités territoriales et les
maires et ils s'organisent de leur mieux
pour permettre à leur personnel de
reprendre leur poste dans le strict
respect des consignes sanitaires que le
gouvernement ait établi et avec les
moyens matériels dont ils disposent
toutefois on le sait tous le risque zéro
n'existe pas en particulier certaines
décisions qui devront tôt ou tard être
prises telles que la réouverture
progressive des écoles on vient d'en
parler suscite des craintes parmi les
élus du fait aussi pas seulement mais
aussi du risque juridique qu'ils seront
amenés à prendre
c'est d'ailleurs l'esprit de la
proposition de loi déposée cette semaine
par notre collègue hervé maurey je note
également la problématique du respect
des règles sanitaires parmi les gens du
voyage et leur installation dans les
zones d'accueil face aux inquiétudes
persistantes
envisagez-vous un éventuel aménagement
des règles de responsabilité
or le cas de faute grave dans un
contexte d' état d'urgence sanitaire
prolongé pour répondre la parole des
tableaux nabeul garde des sceaux
ministre de la justice il avait la
parole madame la ministre
si monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
votre préoccupation médiateur bocal
rejoint celle du gouvernement
il serait en effet inconcevable qu élus
locaux ou entrepreneurs employeurs
privés qui s'engagent dans la reprise le
fasse avec la crainte de voir leur
responsabilité juridique engagée et sur
ce point je souhaiterais pouvoir vous
rassurer les règles qui sont posées par
le code pénal pour engager la
responsabilité des élus locaux ou des
employeurs privés pour mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui ou bien pour homicide ou
blessures involontaires ces règles sont
restrictives elle repose sur la
recherche d'un comportement sciemment
dangereux d'une prise délibérée d'un
risque au mépris de la sécurité des
autres la responsabilité pénale ne peut
donc être recherchée que sur la base
soit d'une faute délibérée en cas de
violation délibérée d'une loi ou un
règlement qui pose d'une obligation
particulière de prudence ou de sécurité
soit d'une faute caractérisée en
l'absence de normes ce qui signifie dans
ce cas qu'il faut avoir conscience de la
mise en danger d'autrui
en s'affranchissant de ce que le bon
sens impose en matière de droit du
travail c'est à dire de responsabilité
civile l'assemblée plénière de la cour
de cassation juge que l'employeur qui
prend les mesures de prévention
nécessaires respecte ses obligations
légales en matière de protection de la
santé des salariés
autrement dit l'obligation de
l'employeur n'est pas une obligation de
résultat mais une obligation de moyens
renforcés
au regard de ce cadre juridique
monsieur le sénateur je ne vois pas
comment les élus locaux ou les
employeurs qui donnerait les
instructions nécessaires afin d'assurer
notamment le respect des gestes
barrières et des dispositifs de sécurité
pourraient voir leur responsabilité
engagée
si des clarifications textuel
apparaissait nécessaire
bien évidemment nous pourrions y
réfléchir avec vous si vocal jaune de
moyens renforcés
oui je profite pour dire à l'enfant de
gouvernement et au premier ministre en
accord avec le président du sénat au
niveau de la délégation aux
collectivités locales et après avoir
auditionné les grandes associations père
de france département région nous sommes
en train de finaliser après les annonces
d'hier un protocole avec douze mesures
prioritaires que nous allons proposer au
gouvernement pour être vraiment au
niveau du sénat et des associations dans
ce partenariat que vous avez souhaité
c'était le moment de le dire merci merci
monsieur le président la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue alain
richard pour le groupe de la république
en marche
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
de l'éducation nationale
parmi les objectifs majeurs du grand
plan de déconfinement bien sûr se
présente au centre
la première étape de la reprise de
l'enseignement public et l'enseignement
du service public de l'enseignement que
exactement dans l'école élémentaire donc
7 millions d'élèves et leurs familles et
350 mille professeurs aujourd'hui encore
subsistent et nous nous en recevant
témoignages de nos collègues amis et
élus locaux
subsiste quelques difficultés de
compréhension et donc je souhaiterais
beaucoup que vous puissiez nous
répondent de façon précisément sur trois
points donc le bruit de gaulle
sanitaires applicables va être publié
vendredi
est-ce qu'il comportera des
préconisations à mieux nécessaire pour
les activités périscolaires et notamment
le nettoyage des salles la restauration
et les activités de garderie
deuxièmement l'annoncera faite aux
familles des enfants qui sont invités à
venir à l'école mais je pense que cette
annonce devrait aller plus loin que la
semaine immédiatement à venir mais
prévoir ou moins les deux semaines
suivantes de manière que les familles
puissent s'organiser et enfin pour
chaque commune dans chaque école il faut
que l'éducation nationale communique au
maire gestionnaire le nombre de salles
où va se dérouler l'enseignement ou
d'autres activités et les horaires sur
lesquels vont se dérouler les activités
puisque pour que le service soit opérant
il faut évidemment une collaboration
organisée avec les collectivités
territoriales
lesquels ont aussi un ensemble de
mesures complexes à prendre notamment de
mouvements de personnel de préparation
méthodologique des nouveaux process donc
il faut que nous soyons au clair on a
souvent appréciée dans cette maison
monsieur nuits d'istres la netteté de
votre groupe de votre propos elle sera
particulièrement bienvenu aujourd'hui
répandre la parole du tourisme de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse me
suis bloqué monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur alain richard votre
question permet de voir le spectre des
choses qui concerne ceux des confidences
colère premiers éléments le protocole
sanitaire
ce protocole sanitaire vous l'avez dit
il sera diffusé vendredi
on est dans la dernière ligne droite
avec consultation des associations
d'élus des organisations syndicales mais
l'entente du lait surtout basé sur le
travail du conseil scientifique et des
autorités sanitaires
il est indépassable autrement dit si on
ne le respecte pas on n'ouvre pas une
école loin ou un établissement
ce protocole gelé là il a été travaillé
avec le bureau veritas pour avoir des
fiches très clair sur chacun des sujets
et sur les sujets que vous évoquez comme
la cantine l'internât toute la
désinfection des locaux
tous ces points seront traités et donc
on doit les respecter c'est le sujet le
plus national en réalité le plus cadran
des trois sujets deuxième sujet c'est la
doctrine d'accueil c'est à dire quels
sont les enfants qui viennent quand
comment et ceci suppose vous l'avez dit
une communication avec les familles ce
que je demandais aux recteurs et oden et
avec eux à l'ensemble des acteurs de
l'éducation nationale c'est de faire ce
que nous avons réussi à faire pendant le
confinement c'est à dire communiquer
avec les familles
très en amont du 11 dès que l'on
commence à avoir une organisation locale
défini et on a vu dans le propos du
premier ministre que c'était une
organisation spécifique à chaque fois et
bien l'école et la famille comme unique
notamment pour savoir si la famille
souhaite envoyer les que l'enfant à
l'école
si ça n'est pas le cas c'est un
enseignement à distance qui se réalise
car l'instruction est obligatoire même à
distance soit tout simplement pour voir
quel est l'emploi du temps de l'enfant
et comment les choses s'organisent
cette communication entre les acteurs
est fondamentale et notamment entre
l'école et la famille et puis en
troisième lieu une doctrine et
pédagogiques et éducatives sur le plan
pédagogique on est au coeur de la
compétence de l'éducation nationale sur
le plan éducatif c'est aussi avec les
communes et sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
le dialogue comme une école et est
fondamental vous l'avez dit et là bien
entendu c'est de la co construction avec
les maires qui se réalise sur tous les
aspects pratiques comme ceux que vous
avez mentionné c'est à dire par exemple
le nombre de salles disponibles mais
aussi pour évaluer ensemble le
nombre d'enfants qui viennent
l'organisation générale la coopération
complète qui doit exister entre
l'éducation nationale et les communes je
dois dire qu'avec les associations
d'élus avec qui nous avons encore parlé
ce matin avec le premier ministre
le climat est à la confiance et le
climat est à la co construction merci la
parole et notre collègue ronan dantec
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen de la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les mines et chers
collègues hier à l'assemblée nationale
le premier ministre a présenté des
grandes les règles du déconfinement
progressif de notre pays en insistant
sur l'absolue nécessité d'un strict
respect jusqu'au 11 mai du cadre
actuellement fixée et sur l'application
tout aussi street après cette date d'un
ensemble de gestes barrières qui en
appelle à la responsabilité et au
civisme de chacun
le groupe rdse partage globalement le
plan présenté qui correspond à une
analyse lucide nourrit d'avis
scientifiques sur l'extrême gravité de
cette crise unique dans notre histoire
nous saluons la volonté de l'état de
s'appuyer sur les collectivités
territoriales dans sa mise en oeuvre en
reconnaissant la diversité des
situations
il est bien trop tôt pour tirer des
enseignements définitifs de la période
que nous vivons mais probablement
arriverons nous à la conclusion que nous
ne sommes efficaces que lorsque les deux
puissances publiques que sont l'état et
les collectivités arrive parfaitement à
se coordonner
certains points de ce plan nécessite
encore des précisions d'où cette
question avec deux interrogations
précises concernant les masques madame
la ministre la phrase du premier
ministre disant fière que des masques
seront disponibles pour les collégiens
je cite nous avions été attentif qui
n'auraient pas réussi à se procurer nous
a surpris et mérite explication première
question donc est ce à dire que pour
nombre de familles ces masques seront à
leur charge
un collégien prenant les transports
publics pourraient avoir besoin de
quatre masques pour une journée complète
ce qui se traduirait par une dépense
pour une famille avec les masques des
parents de plusieurs dizaines d'euros
par mois est cependant potentiellement
de nombreux
si nous avions si nous avons bien
compris que les seces et les
associations pour intervenir pour les
personnes en situation de précarité
l'état at-il prévu une aide pour les
ménages salariés modestes pour qui cet
achat représentera une charge importante
aux risques de l'utilisation de masques
périmés ou ne répondant pas aux normes
cette aide pourrait par exemple prendre
la forme d'une réévaluation de l'april
d'activité et ainsi être facilement
distribués par les caf pour vous
répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur merci de cette question je
voudrais apporter la réponse la plus
claire possible à la question que vous
avez posé une réponse à une question
vous n'avez pas posée mais que vous
laquelle vous avez sûrement tellement
pensé qu'il me semble nécessaire de
pouvoir préciser les choses en la
matière et oui comme disait l'autre
c'est pas votre question mais c'est
quand même ma réponse à leurs
prédécesseurs monsieur le premier
ministre
j'en ai beaucoup le président monsieur
le sénateur donc sur la question de la
distribution des masques aux collégiens
nous l'avons dit les masques seront le
port du masque sera obligatoire pour les
professeurs bien entendu quels que
soient les niveaux d'enseignement et à
partir de la 6e 6e et 5e au moment de la
rentrée des classes pour les collégiens
bien entendu c'est l'éducation nationale
l'état qui fournira les masques le sens
de mon propos hier c'était de dire et
c'est important de bien comprendre que
s'agissant des collégiens évidemment
l'état fournira les masques mais que nos
concitoyens vont fabriquer des masques
vont disposer de masques que certains
acteurs les employeurs les associations
des collectivités territoriales vont
mettre à leur disposition et vont
acheter des masques ils vont les acheter
dans la grande distribution dans les
pharmacies dans tous les réseaux on peut
acquérir cet instrument qui sera parfois
obligatoire dans certains cas parfois
recommandé et dont les âges ne sera peut
dès lors pas nécessairement obligatoire
donc sur cette question je veux vous
rassurer dire les choses le plus
clairement possible sur la question que
vous avez failli poser à laquelle je
tiens à répondre
qui est qui étaient déjà contenues dans
mon discours d'hier
mais je n'ai pas forcément été
suffisamment précis où je veux aller
peut-être encore un peu plus loin que ce
que j'ai dit hier c'est à dire
l'accompagnement par l'état des
collectivités territoriales qui vont
faire l'acquisition de masques pour
aider à fournir l'ensemble de notre
population en masque à compter du 11 mai
j'ai indiqué hier que pour encourager
cette acquisition général de masque dès
lors que nous avions la certitude que
nous pouvions équipes et les soignants
dans la durée l'état s'est engagé à
rembourser accompagner les collectivités
à hauteur de 50% des masques qu'ils
achèteraient le cadre d'un prix de
référence à compter du moment où je
faisais cette annonce mais après avoir
écouté ce matin les associations d'élus
locaux que nous avons rencontrés avec
beaucoup des membres du gouvernement
après les avoir entendues développer un
certain nombre d'arguments je crois que
il les plus justes de d'étendre ce
dispositif à toutes les commandes de
masques passé depuis que le président de
la république a évoqué la date du 11 mai
parce que dès lors que le président la
république évoque le 13 avril la date du
11 mai il me semble que toutes les
commandes qui ont été passées dans le
par les collectivités theuriau par les
collectivités territoriales
pardon à partir du 13 avril doivent
bénéficier du même du même
accompagnement et de la même nuit même
encouragements je dirais que celui que
l'état propose proposé hier par ma voix
hier à la tribune
donc voilà les choses sont claires
s'agissant des collégiens l'état
fournira et s'agissant de l'ensemble des
commandes passées par les collectivités
territoriales pour équiper les
populations de masquer l'état
accompagnera pour les commandes qui sont
passés à compter du 13 avril
merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue pascal savoldelli pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
une question mérite d'être posée si
personne ne souhaite ni le président de
la république niveaux de gouvernement ni
le parlement ni les élus locaux ni les
français les françaises vivre une
deuxième vague d'épidémie et en porter
la responsabilité l'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence sanitaire petit
justifier un confinement de la
démocratie
dès le 20 mars nous avons exprimé nos
plus vives réserves sur un transfert
massif des prérogatives du parlement
vers l'exécutif notre inquiétude a été
malheureusement fondé depuis cette date
le parlement est réduit au rôle de
figurant de visioconférence en
visioconférence notre pouvoir de
contrôle et mis en scène pour tenter de
masquer la réalité
le président a décidé le parlement est
écartée du débat les ordonnances sont
prises pour de multiples projets de loi
déposés pour être immédiatement adoptée
quand nous questionnons nous nous
proposons c'est cause toujours
et quand je dis le nous ce n'est pas
l'exclusivité l'exclusivité de notre
groupe
emmanuel macron bien seul mais il en a
fait le choix a décidé d'un processus de
sortie du confinement le 11 mai je le
cite quoi qu'il en coûte
seul il n'a pas décidé en tout cas des
mesures d'ampleur pour produire les
masques les tests les médicaments et en
assurer le suivi
avec mon groupe je vous demande monsieur
le premier ministre de rendre le pouvoir
au parlement
l'épisode d'hier à l'assemblée nationale
n'est pas acceptable
la mission de représentation nationale
n'est pas seulement formuler un accord
ou un désaccord
sauf à poser la question de confiance
alors confiance ou défiance confiance ou
défiance pour la prise en compte de
propositions exprimées ici et sur tous
les bancs monsieur le premier ministre
nous vous demandons de considérer la
démocratie comme une ordonnance face à
l'épidémie
jusqu'à sa fin en acceptant le débat
avant les décisions
vous ne pouvez pas prorogé ainsi vos
plein pouvoir jusqu'à la fin juillet
monsieur le premier ministre c'est halle
avec la démocratie et grâce à elle que
nous gagnerons tous ensemble la bataille
contre locaux vides 19 pour vous
répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
donc selon vous nous aurions annoncé à
la démocratie le gouvernement ne
seraient pas présents quand les
parlementaires lui pose des questions il
ne répondrait pas présent il ne
répondrait pas présent lorsque les
commissions permanentes de l'assemblée
nationale ou du sénat lui demande de
venir et de dire des choses et parfois
de travailler et d'exposer des
hypothèses lesquels ne sont pas retenu
le premier ministre et les membres du
gouvernement ne répondrait pas aux
missions aux demandes des missions
d'information constituée dans telle ou
telle assemblée la vérité monsieur le
sénateur c'est que depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire
le gouvernement a répondu à toutes les
demandes formulées par le sénat et par
l'assemblée nationale que nous
transmettons et monsieur le président du
sénat le répète souvent et je l'en
remercie toutes les mesures y compris
celles qui ne relève absolument pas
d'une magnifique latif toutes les
mesures qui sont prises dans
l'application de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire aux deux assemblées afin de
faire en sorte et c'est bien naturel que
l'information soit complète sur les
mesures qui sont prises que la la
création de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
monsieur le sénateur n'est pas le fait
du gouvernement
elle est le fait d'une loi qui a été
discuté qui a été débattue et qui a été
approuvé
vous avez parfaitement le droit monsieur
le sénateur d'avoir voté contre ou de
voter contre
c'est très respectable mais ce n'est pas
parce que vous avez voté contre
que votre vote commande l'ensemble dans
la représentation nationale et des deux
assemblées il se trouve que l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat ont considéré que
cet état d'urgence sanitaire était
nécessaire il se trouve qu'ils ont
débattu et a ajouté un certain nombre de
dispositions et là où je trouve que
c'est un peu curieux pour un sénateur je
vous le dis très franchement monsieur le
sénateur que c'est un peu curieux pour
un sénateur de formuler la question que
vous n'êtes formuler c'est que le projet
de loi sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire a
été très largement discutés dans cet
hémicycle très largement corrigé
améliorée je veux bien dire tous les
mots que vous voudrez pour justement
limiter au plus près les compétences du
gouvernement vous en souvenez
parfaitement
il s'agissait non pas d'avoir une
habilitation général mais de fixer dû
premièrement deuxièmement troisièmement
jusqu'au 9e mans l'ensemble des
compétences
ce que le parlement accepte et que le
gouvernement puisse faire usage donc
pardon monsieur le sénateur mais soit ce
que vous faites ne sert à rien soit ce
que vous faites sert à quelque chose
or ce que vous faites sert à quelque
chose il a amélioré la loi sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
maintenant attendez je vous réponds
l'état d'urgence sanitaire a été
travaillée et améliorée grâce au
parlement et c'est nous qui appliquons
la loi quand il faut l'appliquer et je
trouve que ça parfaitement naturel sur
la prorogation et sur l'ensemble des
mesures à prendre
nous viendrons devant le parlement
discuter des mesures à prendre pour
participer au déconfinement pour le cas
échéant prorogé en effet cet état
d'urgence sanitaire pour vérifier à
quelle condition il doit l'être et avec
quel type de contrôle nous ne vivons pas
des temps normaux monsieur le sénateur
si on pense que l'arsenal juridique
préexistant permettait de régler la
question de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
alors il faut le dire mais je constate
que le parlement le gouvernement ont
fait un choix différent et je respecte
pour ma part en tant que premier
ministre tout ce que dit la loi et tout
ce que dit le parlement vous ne pouvez
pas me demander d'aller au delà voilà
nous respectons la loi nous respectons
scrupuleusement la constitution
je me suis exprimé hier devant
l'assemblée nationale en faisant usage
des dispositions de l'article 50-1
monsieur le sénateur j'aurais
parfaitement pu je ne dis pas que ça
aurait été mieux je pense que ça aurait
été moins bien j'aurais parfaitement pu
aller faire ça dans une conférence de
presse à la télévision
j'aurais tout à fait pu le faire
j'aurais mis des cartes derrière moi
j'aurais mis des chiffres derrière moi
ça aurait été plus claire pour les
français peut-être je les fais à
l'assemblée nationale parce que
l'assemblée nationale comme le sénat
bien entendu c'est le lieu où on débat
des sujets d'intérêts nationaux
c'est le lieu où on peut prendre une
position gelé d'hier monsieur le
sénateur les parlementaires ce ne sont
pas des commentateurs de l'action
publique ils prennent une position
politique
ils sont pour ces respectables ils sont
contre ces respectables
ils s'abstiennent c'est respectable mais
en tout cas il ne commande pas ils
votent c'est une mesure de respect
vis-à-vis de l'assemblée nationale c'est
une mesure de respect vis-à-vis du par
je l'assumé je le défends est
franchement monsieur le sénateur je suis
certain qu'on pourrait se retrouver sur
ce point la parole est maintenant notre
collègue stefan pieds noirs pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues c'est le premier ministre hier
vous avez lors de votre déclaration à
l'assemblée nationale esquissé les
conditions du déconfinement scolaire
question qui est évidemment au coeur des
préoccupations des familles
après une communication il faut bien le
dire quelque peu cacophonique de la part
de l'exécutif sur le sujet vous avez en
quelque sorte relativiser l'importance
du 11 mai que d'autres avaient fixé
comme un objectif jamais sur notre
territoire national jamais nos écoles
avaient été fermées
même en période de guerre et donc je
mesure l'ampleur de la tâche qui est la
vôtre
durant cette période si délicate que
nous connaissons je ne vous ferai donc
pas l'affront ni le plaisir d'ailleurs
de me ranger dans le camp de ceux qui
connaissent ou qui prétendent connaître
l'ensemble des solutions d'emblée comme
vous avez pu le signaler
hier tout au plus me permettrai de vous
attirer votre attention sur un certain
nombre de questions qui restent en
suspens et qui méritent de mon point de
vue des éclaircissements d'abord comment
concilier l'urgence pédagogique
vis-à-vis des décrocheurs alors que le
retour en classe est basé sur le
volontariat
ensuite alors que nos professeurs sont
très largement mobilisés comment assurer
une présence en cours et en même temps
continuer l'enseignement à distance pour
ceux qui n'auront pas repris le chemin
de l'école
sur la base du volontariat par ailleurs
un certain nombre de questions
concernent aussi directement les
compétences des collectivités locales
émérite et mérite quelles qu'elles
soient éclaircis parce que beaucoup
d'élus nous interroge
quels sont les préconisations du
gouvernement concernant la restauration
scolaire
les transports scolaires les activités
périscolaires qui fournira les masses
qui les paiera toutes ces questions sont
importantes et il ne faudrait pas que
que l'on fasse
orthez uniquement sur les épaules des
mères la charge de la gestion de cette
crise je suis convaincu comme nombre de
mes collègues que les maires feront tout
ce qu'ils peuvent mettrons tout en
oeuvre pour réussir ce déconfinement
mais ils ne peuvent pas être tenus
responsables d'éventuelles
contaminations qui auront lieu au sein
des établissements scolaires
sur ce dernier point en particulier
monsieur le premier ministre pouvez-vous
leur apporter une quelconque garantie
je remercie pour vous répondre la parole
et à monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur
blanc caire monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur pieds-noirs
beaucoup de questions pour deux minutes
mais je vais y répondre et je crois
d'abord vous répondre sur la question de
méthode dès le début le gouvernement a
affiché une méthode celle ci est de
poser des hypothèses de recueillir des
réactions et notamment celle du
parlement de l'otan tenir compte pour de
nouvelles hypothèses de revenir devant
et de continuer ainsi à préciser les
choses c'est exactement ce qui se passe
tout au long du mois d'avril un point
clé était le discours du premier
ministre hier et nous avons encore du
travail sur certaines précisions
comme nous l'avons fait ce matin avec
les associations d'élus comme nous le
faisons en vous écoutant si vous avez
des solutions sur certains des points
néanmoins maintenant le degré de
précision est assez fort sur les trois
domaines que j'ai déjà évoqué c'est à
dire le protocole sanitaire sur le
protocole sanitaire vous avez une
réponse sur chacun des points que vous
avez mentionné cantine internat à cour
de récréation abords des établissements
tout ceci est réglée sera une référence
nationale et donc je crois que c'est
très clair sur le sujet du décrochage et
de la lutte contre le décrochage
je crois que votre parti parle de deux
d'obligation scolaire j'en déduis que
vous prenez l'idée que nous allions
chercher les enfants dans les familles
nous disons non à l'école même si les
familles ne veulent pas ce serait tout
simplement pas applicable donc soyons
raisonnables j'ai entendu dire
cacophonie aussi parce que le président
aurait dit quelque chose de différent de
ce que j'aurais dit c'est faux
le président a dit exactement ce que
j'avais commencé a annoncé précédemment
à l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire le
fait que en réalité la seule chose que
l'on peut dire dans de telles
circonstances c'est à dire l'instruction
est obligatoire si elle est obligatoire
ça signifie que soit l'élève va à
l'école physiquement ce que nous
souhaitons soit il ya un enseignement à
distance garantie et oui notre priorité
sera d'aller chercher au maximum ses 4 %
des élèves décrocheurs que nous avons
eues pendant le confinement ce qui au
passage était
les meilleurs chiffres d'europe c'est
encore trop élevé mais c'est un des
meilleurs chiffres aujourd'hui et enfin
en troisième lieu
vous vous demandez comment va être
comment va s'organiser la communication
avec les familles j'ai commencé à le
dire nous allons être très attentifs à
ça il faut une personnalisation des
parcours
ce que nous voulons c'est qu'il y ait
une sorte de feuille de route niveau par
niveau élèves par élève pour le mois de
mai et juin parce que oui ce mois de mai
juin 2020 est forcément très différent
de tout ce que nous avons connu et nous
sommes en ce moment en train de le co
construire avec tous les acteurs non
seulement de l'éducation mais de la
société française je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre parole est
maintenant à notre collègue corinne
féret pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain savez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues si vous permettez
monsieur le président je souhaiterais
remercier le premier ministre au nom du
groupe socialiste et républicain pour
les propos qu'il a tenus à l'égard
d'henri weber la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et de ses conséquences tant
sociale qu'économique met en lumière le
rôle primordial des collectivités
territoriales et des élus locaux
je veux ici saluer l'engagement de ces
femmes et ces hommes est les remercier
de leur action au quotidien pour leur
population tandis que l'état peine à
arrêter des orientations claires et à
fournir des tests à la population des
masques et équipements personnels
mobilisés
ce sont les collectivités qui pallie les
manques assure la continuité des
services
la continuité de l'état hier le premier
ministre a reconnu le rôle essentiel que
jouent les élus locaux dans cette crise
ce matin il a rencontré les associations
d'élus dont un dans un exercice étrange
une concertation a posteriori des
décisions en leur confiant les clés d'un
déconfinement territorialisées hélas
augmenter la pression qui pèse sur leurs
épaules
la reconnaissance est une bonne chose
mais ce dont ils ont besoin c'est de
moyens pour assumer assurer leur mission
en cette crise pèse lourdement sur les
finances des collectivités en métropole
comme dans les territoires ultramarins
le confinement a provoqué un
effondrement des recettes et je pense
notamment pour les communes touristiques
quand on parle de taxe de séjour taxe de
casino c'est le cas dans mon département
du calvados
et également une explosion des dépenses
le sénat a chiffré l'impact sur les
finances locales à hauteur de 4
milliards neuf cent mille et ses
difficultés ne sont pas liées aux seuls
confinement et se prolongeront encore
longtemps avec la baisse ddm théo de la
cvae le groupe socialiste et républicain
tire donc la sonnette d'alarmé
il n'est pas raisonnable de vouloir
transférer des responsabilités aux
collectivités territoriales dans un flou
général et sans moyens aussi madame
madame la ministre ma question est
simple
quels moyens allez vous proposer pour
épauler les collectivités je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
l'état la ministre
la cohésion des territoires des
relations avec les collectivités à
madame gouro vers la parole madame la
sénatrice corinne féret je voulais vous
dire j'ai une conviction absolument
profonde c'est que l'état et les
collectivités territoriales doivent
travailler ensemble
une conviction chevillée au corps je
dirais je n'ai pas besoin de vous
expliquer pourquoi
deuxièmement la réunion de ce matin avec
les associations d'élus n'avait rien
d'étrange
elle était prévue bien sûr au lendemain
du discours du premier ministre
justement puisque nous avons toujours
dit qu'il y aurait un cadre et
qu'ensuite les politiques serait
déclinée sur le plan local et je voulais
vous préciser que nous avons menées
avant la réunion de ce matin énormément
de réunions avec les élus locaux et des
associations d'élus auparavant pour
préparer cette période vous parler
particulièrement des problèmes
financiers des collectivités locales
dans un deuxième temps nous sommes tout
à fait conscients bien sûr des
difficultés d'ailleurs nous avions pris
dès le début de la crise due qu'au vu
des décisions pour faciliter au fond
notamment les dépenses imprévues comme
on dit dans les budgets des
collectivités territoriales avec des
facilités de lignes de crédit
voilà nous avions déjà facilité et nous
avions demandé aux préfets de mobiliser
des avances de fiscalité ou de dotation
en cas de besoin pour que des communes
ne soient pas en difficulté
bien sûr la deuxième chose que je
voulais vous dire il va y avoir les
dépenses supplémentaires liées à la mise
en place du déconfinement et nous le
savons le premier ministre vient d'abord
de d'expliquer ou d'apporter une réponse
avec les masques il y en aura d'autres
et nous travaillons avec le ministre du
budget et mon collègue sébastien lecornu
nous travaillons à ce que ces dépenses
soient bien identifiés et puis enfin il
y a à plus long terme
bien évidemment les difficultés que
pourront compter est les collectivités
locales soit par dépenses
supplémentaires comme je viens de le
dire mais soit aussi par manque de
recettes et nous avons déjà identifié
les communes touristiques
les communes ultramarines les dm théo
pour les départements etc
nous avons identifié est d'ailleurs le
premier miss a confié une mission au
député cazeneuve l'homologue de notre
ami bockel du sénat pour évaluer la
situation des collectivités
territoriales et c'est tous ensemble que
nous apporterons une réponse merci l'ami
nice la parole est maintenant madame la
présidente valérie létard pour le groupe
de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
ameline montchalin secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes
déjà affaibli par le brr excite avant
l'éclatement de la crise sanitaire
l'union européenne peut-elle être
aujourd'hui une victime collatérale du
coc vite 19 alors que nous avons plus
que jamais besoin de l'union européenne
les problèmes européens semble devant
nous intransigeance des pays du nord
pour une solidarité européenne davantage
intégré choix américains des allemands
pour l'application de tracking qui
laisse la france bien seul sur la scène
européenne avec son stop qu'ovide
fermeture des frontières restrictions de
circulation des biens et des personnes
les impacts de la crise sanitaire sont
très nombreux et touchent beaucoup
d'aspects de notre quotidien
ce sont autant de difficultés que
l'union européenne aura à surmonter pour
permettre une véritable relance
c'est dans ce contexte que l'on observe
aussi aujourd'hui des replis aux
frontières que l'on n'avait plus observé
depuis schengen comme me l'a indiqué mon
collègue mon collègue claude caire mais
aussi tous mes collègues frontalier de
nombreux points de passage vers
l'allemagne ont été fermées des
alsaciens travailler en allemagne
doivent attendre des heures aux postes
frontières pour des contrôles
administratifs et policiers tatillon
générant des tensions de part et d'autre
de la frontière
derrière ces problématiques se joue
pourtant l'avenir de l'europe dont
l'enjeu est bien celui d'une coopération
décisives et stratégique entre les états
membres
si aujourd'hui les étagères chacun de
leur côté la crise sanitaire et c'est
bien logique
la vie doit continuer et repartir
maintenant et des échanges
transfrontaliers quelle qu'en soit la
nature s'organiser dans les meilleures
conditions de sécurité et de bonne
volonté dans cette optique madame la
ministre
quels sont vos échanges avec nos pays
voisins en particulier l'allemagne pour
faciliter la situation des travailleurs
frontaliers
plus globalement quel échange avez vous
engager avec l'ensemble de nos voisins
pour anticiper la sortie de crise et
permettre un retour progressif à la
normale dans cette période où nous avons
tous besoin d'une europe qui parle d'une
seule voix d'une europe forte relance
industrielle enjeux sanitaires
transition écologique et numérique
nous comptons sur l'action de la france
pour qu'une dynamique partenariale
européenne puisse être véritablement
relancé je vous remercie encore et pour
la parole et par la secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes à l'âme
de montchalin vous avez la parole de la
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et madame la
sénatrice valérie létard effectivement
nos concitoyens des territoires
frontaliers ne peuvent pas et ne seront
pas les oubliés du déconfinement la
frontière qui était pour eux invisible
est subitement réapparu avec cette crise
et je sais le désarroi et la souffrance
que cela a pu générer
je pense à ses parents séparés qu'ils ne
peuvent pas aller voir leurs enfants de
l'autre côté la frontière de ces
apprentis qui ne peuvent plus aller
travailler dans les entreprises
allemandes de ces familles qui ne
peuvent plus aller rendre visite à leurs
proches dans les hôpitaux de l'autre
côté
alors madame la sénatrice il n'y a pas
eu
de fermeture complète des frontières il
ne doit pas y en avoir
c'est l'objectif bien sûr au plan
franco-allemand et du président de la
république et de la chancelière et jean
yves le drian lardy très récemment à et
comme à son homologue au plan local
je tiens vraiment elle salue ici la mise
en oeuvre d'une coopération quotidienne
entre les trois länder frontaliers
allemands et la région grand est
cette grande région aussi qui associe la
belgique le luxembourg l'allemagne et la
france au niveau local qui fonctionnent
très activement au niveau national nous
avons travaillé avec muriel pénicaud
bruno le maire gérald darmanin a
vraiment garantir pour les travailleurs
frontaliers les mêmes droits que les
autres salariés et à neutraliser les
effets de la crise sur le régime social
et fiscal français et allemands nous
partageons maintenant avec les autres
pays voisins un même objectif nous
donner les moyens d'une reprise de la
vie économique est quotidienne tout en
garantissant un haut niveau de sécurité
sanitaire sécurité sanitaire qui peut
imposer encore pendant quelques temps
des contrôles proportionnée et
réciproque et ces derniers jours j'ai pu
réunir avec mon homologue allemand tous
les acteurs de la coopération
transfrontalière pour identifier les
points précis difficulté et nous
travaillons sous l'autorité du premier
ministre avec laurent nonies à les
résoudre
cette même consultation je la mène avec
les élus locaux proches du luxembourg de
la suisse de l'italie alors cette
coopération frontalière vous l'avais dit
à valeur d'exemple dans notre
coordination européenne dans son
ensemble et la france et l'allemagne ont
une responsabilité partagée dans cette
relance être le moteur du consensus
européen aujourd'hui pour la reprise
économique mais également demain pour
renforcer notre autonomie stratégique
européennes clés comme vous l'avez dit
face à cette crise dont nous devons
sortir ensemble et de boue
merci mes chers collègues les
conclusions adoptées par la conférence
des présidents réunie ce jour sont
consultables sur notre site et en
l'absence d'observation je les considère
comme adopté je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement auront lieu le mercredi 6
mai à 15h vous remercions monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres je
vais chers collègues levé la séance
notre prochaine séance aura lieu le
lundi 4 mai
4 mai à 14h30 pour la déclaration du
gouvernement en application de l'article
50-1 de la constitution suivie d'un
débat et d'un vote relatives à la
stratégie nationale du plan de
déconfinement par le cas de la lutte
contre l'épidémie de comics disney la
séance s'est donc levé chacun observera
bien les règles que notre questeur
délégué a rappelé en conférence des
présidents et je l'en remercie
et il sera utile que les présidents de
groupe les fasse partager ses règles
pour la poursuite de la sortie du
confinement au sénat je vous remercie
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur public sénat vous
l'aurez noté
à la fin de cette séance le président du
sénat gérard larcher a également précisé
à l'ordre du jour pour lundi où se
déroulera donc ce jour là le débat sur
le plan de déconfinement au sénat un
débat donc qui sera enrichie avec
notamment un certain nombre de
consultations qui auront eu lieu
et bien tout au long de cette semaine
notamment les élus locaux par le premier
ministre avec ensuite un vote de la part
du sénat notez qu ensuite et bien les
sénateurs pourront également débattre et
voter du le projet de loi sur la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
alors bien sûr cette séance a été
largement consacré au plan de
déconfinement qui est entamée le 11 mai
et la mesure qu il focalise le plus
l'attention des français sur ce plan de
déconfinement c'est d'abord bien la
reprise de l'école la possibilité
d'aller à l'école et je suis avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel blanquer rebond jour en jour
merci de répondre à nos questions vous
avez eu plusieurs questions lors de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement tout d'abord pouvez-vous
rassurer les parents les parents
suffisamment pour qu'ils remettent leurs
enfants à l'école
car en effet bien certains continuent de
souligner le flou puisque on avait
d'abord fermer les écoles en disant que
les enfants étaient premiers
propagateurs et puis aussi parce qu'il
ya cette nouvelle aujourd'hui ses
nouvelles inquiétantes sur cette maladie
la maladie de kawasaki sur laquelle des
hôpitaux commencent à donner l alerte
sera un certain nombre d'enfants qui
sont atteints bien entendu il faut
d'abord rappeler à quel point l'école
c'est important
bien sûr le coc vie de 19 est un sujet
essentiel qui est notre point de repère
pour régler les questions sanitaires est
en tout cas fixé un cadre sanitaire très
strict
mais en même temps nul ne doit oublier
que fréquenter l'école c'est essentiel
est que nous sommes en ce moment en
train de perdre les enfants les plus
fragiles qui décrochent du système
scolaire et que par ailleurs pour
l'ensemble des élèves quel que soit leur
classe sociale quelles que soient leurs
difficultés scolaires ou leur facilité
scolaire il ya un besoin d'aller à
l'école s'il faut quand même le
réaffirmer aujourd'hui la majorité des
pays du monde sont engagés dans le
déconfinement scolaire bien sûr ça n'est
pas facile
c'est une situation inédite et des
confiné et complexes et j'étais encore
avec pas en correspondance avec
plusieurs ministres de l'éducation de
différents pays tout le monde affronte
le même type de problème
donc il faut avoir conscience à la fois
de l'impératif du déconfinement scolaire
parce qu'ici fond il faut raisonner a
contrario est ce que l'on voudrait par
exemple que les enfants restent enfermés
pendant des mois et des mois le temps
que l'on trouve un vaccin
bien sûr que non ce les dégâts
psychologiques par exemple serait trop
important donc on est obligé de
raisonner sur ce que c'est que vivre en
période de virus cela oblige donc un
protocole sanitaires très strictes
nous en avons élaboré un il sera public
à partir de vendredi
et c'est le point de repère de toutes
les écoles et de tous les établissements
scolaires
pour le dire autrement aucune école
aucun établissement scolaire n'ouvrira
sans respecter ces protocoles qui vont
quand même loin avec des groupes petits
de 15 élèves et toute une série de
mesures masque en particulier autres
mesures d'hygiène nettoyage mesures
spécifiques pour la cantine pour
l'internât pour la récréation qui
permettent tout simplement d'avoir des
conditions
permettant de développer les gestes
barrière en particulier aujourd'hui
certaines écoles en voit déjà des mails
pour sonder les familles certains mais
le fond et a enfin ce sont des
directeurs d'école un qui disent que
vraiment les conditions sont très
délicates et en clair il un site très
fortement les parents d'élèves à laisser
leurs enfants à la maison qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
non il ne doit pas y avoir de messages
de ce type les messages officiels de
l'éducation nationale partiront au cours
des prochains au cours des prochains
jours
ils sont ils sont là pour justement
expliqué la façon dont on respecte les
gestes barrières et certainement pas
pour créer des inquiétudes alors même
que ceux qui ont pu les écrire
vous n'avez pas encore les éléments dont
je viens de vous parler est ce que votre
plan sur trois semaines avec aller
retour en classe pour certains niveaux
continuent à tenir comme vous l'aviez
annoncé la semaine dernière où est ce
que tous les niveaux vont pouvoir ouvrir
en même temps pour la maternelle et
l'école primaire
si tu veux jouer notre bac c'est d'abord
à lorgues depuis le début nous disons
que cela doit être progressif les ce que
j'avais présenté était donc des
hypothèses qui sont en fait très
indicative pour organiser les choses de
façon progressive
j'avais notamment indiqué que certains
niveaux pouvaient être considérés comme
prioritaires je pense au cp et au cm2 le
système que le premier ministre a
présenté est un système qui permet
encore plus de souplesse localement
c'est à dire c'est un système qui
indique l'impératif du demi groupe qui
indique aussi le fait que c'est bien
d'organiser les choses par niveau et
ensuite c localement en fonction des
particularités locales que l'on organise
cette progressivité donc par exemple on
peut accueillir par groupe de 15
les cp les cm2 la première semaine c'est
un exemple que je donne ceux qui
occupent l'espace puisque on divise la
classe par deux et donc les autres
niveaux viennent la semaine suivante
cette organisation sera à chaque fois
locales elle sera communiquée aux
familles et elle fait qu'un élève à
certains moments sera soit en classe en
petits groupes ce qui d'ailleurs sera
une situation favorable
pédagogiquement soit à l'étude ce qui
sera possible aussi dans certains cas
soient dans des activités co organisé
entre l'éducation et la municipalité de
sport de culture en particulier soit
chez lui dans l'enseignement à distance
ne
pour les familles qui auront choisi
l'enseignement à distance à 100%
ce sera aussi le cas une dernière
question jean michel blanquer vous dites
que votre considération dans la
réouverture des écoles est d'abord
sociale
que répondez vous à ceux qui jugent que
votre objectif à l'objectif de
gouvernement c'est avant tout de
remettre les parents au travail et qui
lisent ainsi le fait que l on met
d'abord les plus jeunes à l'école et
qu'en fait on permet à ceux qui peuvent
se garder tout seul de rester à la
maison les collégiens et lycéens
l'objectif il est d'abord sociale
l'école primaire est notre première
priorité depuis que nous sommes aux
responsabilités depuis trois ans je dis
à quel point l'école primaire est
fondamentale et à quel point dire cela
et social puisque si les élèves n'ont
pas les savoirs fondamentaux consolidé
lors des premières années de la vie
eh bien il ya toute une série de
conséquences sociales négatives ensuite
donc c'est social on le voit près par
exemple pour les cp et ce1 12
nous avons créé ces cp ce1 à 12 dans les
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire avec une
visée sociale c'est plus de trois cent
mille enfants qui sont concernés
oui mais c'est les cp et les ce1 par
exemple pour faire partie de ce qu'ils
font pour entrer en premier et c'est
profondément social un lycéen peut
davantage travailler à distance parce
qu'ils les pays les plus mûrs par
ailleurs le fait que tout ceci contribue
au redémarrage économique
c'est social aussi bien entendu est ce
qu'on pense que le pays ne peut pas
évidemment la crise sociale pour être
très graves si l'économie ne redémarre
pas donc on ne doit pas opposer
l'économique et le social il ya
évidemment des objectifs sociaux directs
mais les objectifs sociaux indirects
passe par l'économie il faut que tout
simplement la france au travail si on
veut qu'il y ait de la de la richesse
nationale à partager entre nous tous et
donc pour financer notre système public
par exemple il faut qu'il y ait de
l'activité économique donc ya pas de
contradiction
et puis ce qui est important c'est la
progressivité on commence par l'école on
poursuit par le collège et j'espère
qu'on pourra aller puisque les coulisses
avant les vacances scolaires avant les
vacances scolaires mais c'est ce qu'on
définit là aussi de manière pragmatique
et progressive en regardant notamment à
la fin du mois de mai où nous en sommes
sur le plan sanitaire dans le pays
eh bien merci à beaucoup jean michel
blanquer d'avoir répondu à mes questions
en attendant que le protocole sanitaire
qui sera rendu public d'ici la fin de la
semaine merci vendredi beaucoup vendredi
je vais à présent accueillir catherine
dumas bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous on vous a entendu tout à l'heure
lors de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement puisque vous
avez interpellé le gouvernement autour
de la situation est bien du tourisme il
faut dire que les chiffres sont
effrayants c'est ce que vous a répondu
d'ailleurs jean baptiste lemoyne moins
100 % pour certaines activités
touristiques pour le tourisme on
comprend bien vu le contexte actuel
oui tout à fait en fait j'ai interpellé
le premier ministre sur le secteur du
tourisme est aussi celui des industries
culturelles qui quelques parcs sont les
deux secteurs qui hier n'ont pas fait
l'objet d' annonce pour le déconfinement
à partir du 11 mai et qui n'ont surtout
pas de date de perspective donc ces
secteurs sont vraiment je dirais est
très très inquiets et donc je souhaitais
savoir quelle serait la position du
gouvernement
avez vous été satisfait par la réponse
du gouvernement
on le voit notamment pour les industries
culturelles pour les salles de
spectacles pour l'instant je n'ai pas
vraiment de solution de trouver tout à
fait alors sur ce dernier sujet des
industries culturelles en effet qui je
le rappelais représente quand même cette
fois plus en pib que l'industrie
automobile donc c'est très très
important pour la france
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de solution
j'ai pour ma part sollicité qu'il y ait
non pas un report des charges mais qu'il
y à une annulation des charges
en ce qui concerne le secteur du
tourisme le ministre main en effet fait
savoir qu'il y avait des négociations
qui étaient en cours avec ce secteur
mais je voulais vraiment rappeler son
attention sur le secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration qui n'a aucune perspective
qui en plus va devoir vivre ce sujet de
département vert au rouge qui
n'aura pas de plage ouverte avant le 2
juin pas de manifestation de plus de 10
personnes et cetera et cetera donc avec
beaucoup d'interrogations et beaucoup de
d'angoise est ce que vous demandez par
exemple comme damien abad le demande
qu'on puisse reconsidérer ce moment la
réouverture notamment des restaurants au
11 mai notamment pour les départements
qui seront classés vert et que cela
puisse être utilisé et non pas que cela
soit repoussée à la fin mai pour une
éventuelle réouverture au mois de juin
alors pour ce secteur donc d'abord tout
d'abord vraiment l'annulation des
charges après en effet selon les
situations je pense qu'il serait
peut-être intéressant qu'on puisse
peut-être avec les préfets d'ailleurs et
les élus locaux
avoir un jugement au cas par cas et en
effet dans les départements vers peut
être accéder à une réouverture plus
rapidement en tout cas que chaque cas
particulier soit étudiée mais ce que je
voudrais aussi dire c'est qu'il est très
important que ces professionnels n'ouvre
que lorsqu'ils seront vraiment prêts
notamment pour des raisons sanitaires
et on peut imaginer que pour certains
restant sa va être difficile c'est
d'être rentable de travailler dans les
conditions ses électeurs les consignes
sanitaires bien sûr c'est tout le sujet
c'est pour ça que je demande un
accompagnement au delà du 30 juin pour
ces métiers merci beaucoup catherine
dumas d'avoir répondu à nos questions
j'ai à présent accueillir le président
du groupe centriste le groupe uc ici au
sénat le sénateur des hauts-de-seine
hervé marseille bonjour un mot tout
d'abord et bien sûr ce qui nous a bien
occupé aujourd'hui et qui a occupé le
parlement depuis hier déjà bien sûr les
annonces du plan de déconfinement au vu
de ce que vous avez entendu du premier
ministre et précision aussi
d'aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
favorables à ce plan de déconfinement
tout et on aura le débat la semaine
prochaine et le départ amélioré et
enrichi puisque il ya des concertations
aujourd'hui même avec les préfets demain
avec ce matin
les 06 et puis avec les partenaires
sociaux donc nous bénéficierons au sénat
d'un plan j'allais dire améliorer
j'espère est en tous les cas réhaussé
d'un motif de satisfaction pour vous de
pouvoir avoir ce plan plus précisée mais
de fait ça ne sera pas la même chose que
cette semaine et certains disent que du
coup les délais encore une fois pour
voter vont et se faire une idée de ce
plan vont être vraiment très court je
crois qu'on avait eu la bonne ligne au
sénat puisque dès le départ nous avions
demandé à avoir un débat global souvenez
vous on nous parlait de tra things on
nous parlait de déconfinement nous nous
avions dit écoutez on veut l'ensemble
des éléments et nous avions obtenu d'en
parler le 5 mai là nous allons avoir
j'allais dire le maximum d'éléments
j'espère le 4 et nous aurons en primeur
en plus le projet de
de loi d'urgence sanitaire numéro 2
puisqu'il faut compléter la loi
d'urgence sanitaire qui s'arrête dans sa
première mouture le 23 mai oui la preuve
roger effectivement jusqu'au 23 juillet
a priori ce sera discuté lundi soir et
peut-être même mardi matin après midi
oui parce que la différence avec
l'assemblée c'est qu'on respecte et
sénateurs et nous nous avons exigé de
pouvoir réunir les groupes pour parler
de du débat et pour pouvoir voter en
ayant la vie des sénateurs alors
justement dans ce plan de déconfinement
et bien il ya une lourde responsabilité
qui pèse sur les épaules des élus locaux
est ce que pour vous les collectivités
aujourd'hui sont armés pour faire face à
la mission que veut leur confier le
gouvernement je crois que il ya un
partenariat évident qui se fait entre le
gouvernement les préfets qui représente
le gouvernement dans chaque département
et puis les élus locaux il faut bien
sortir du confinement et commencé à
retravailler
ceci étant dit il faut le faire avec
toutes les garanties de sécurité
on a déjà obtenu une première
satisfaction aujourd'hui qui a été
annoncé en primeur au sénat c'est le
fait que l'état avait annoncé hier par
la voix du premier ministre qu'il
prenait en charge la moitié du prix des
masques commandés et beaucoup d'élus ont
dit oui mais on a déjà accordé tous ces
masques donc vous avez vu que le premier
ministre a dit d'accord ça sera depuis
le 13 avril les qualités de cette
réaction pendant 7 à motifs de
satisfaction après il ya beaucoup d'élus
et beaucoup de chefs d'entreprises qui
sont inquiets pour leur responsabilité
en disant on me demande de prendre des
décisions me demande d'ouvrir l'école on
me demande d'ouvrir la crèche le patron
dit on me demande de d'ouvrir les
chantiers ou de réouvrir lusine quelle
est ma part de responsabilité
personnelle dans cette affaire c'est la
raison pour laquelle par la voix de jean
marie bockel nous avons posé la question
garde des sceaux et je pense que nous
reviendrons la semaine prochaine
à travers les textes pour améliorer
cette affaire de la responsabilité
hervé maurey le président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire un mot juste pour conclure
sur peut-être la question des
contreparties aux aides de l'état qu'il
devrait y avoir il ya eu notamment un
amendement du groupe centriste la
semaine dernière qui avait été adopté
dans un premier temps pour ne pas aider
les entreprises enregistrées dans des
paradis fiscaux finalement retiré il ya
bien sûr la question du versement des
dividendes aussi est-ce que les annonces
du gouvernement vous suffisent
aujourd'hui où est ce que vous voulez
toujours de pouvoir les inscrire dans la
loi et d'ailleurs y avoir un prochain
collectif budgétaire encore une fois oui
pareil qui aura un projet de loi de
finances numéro trois c'est naturel
puisqu'il ya beaucoup d' annonce
financière il faut adapter le budget je
crois qu'il faut de la clarification
puisque effectivement on sait pas très
bien où on en est on a des propositions
ici au sénat on a des réponses
et puis ensuite il ya des déclarations
ministérielles donc il faut essayer de
mettre tout ça en concordance et sur la
sphère notamment des paradis fiscaux
je crois qu'il faut tirer les
conséquences des déclarations de bruno
le maire et il faudrait pouvoir revenir
sur le sujet sur les dividendes aussi
mais je pense que ce sera l'occasion on
peut les faire 3 de revenir là dessus
vous rendez vous rendez vous sur ce plfr
3 merci merci beaucoup hervé marseille
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
à présent et bien rémi féraud bonjour
sénateur socialiste de paris on vous a
entendu ouvrir et bien le bal des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement un
mot d'abord sur la réponse du premier
ministre at elle été pour vous
satisfaisante vous avez souligné sa
prudence prudence de rigueur donc pour
se plaindre des confinement qui commence
le 11 mai partage pour ma part la
prudence du premier ministre dans son
approche du déconfinement bien plus que
volonté
d'aller vite du président de la
république et au premier ministre a
transformé le 11 mai largement en 2 juin
puisque sont trois semaines de
déconfinement très progressif et très
prudent ça je le partage en revanche je
ne me satisfais pas de la réponse du
premier ministre
mis sur les modalités de reprise de
l'école ni sur son absence de prise en
compte de l'urgence sociale
voilà c'est fait n'avoir pas répondu à
cette question est en soi une réponse
est inquiétante pour beaucoup de
français
et ce qui est comme un motif de
satisfaction avec cette annonce
d'ailleurs que souligne hervé marseille
à l'instant le fait que l'état va
accompagner les collectivités sur leurs
commandes de masques et cela à compter
du 13 avril
c'est un début aussi et bien des dons
l'imaginent pour est bien de tous ces
français à qui on va pouvoir distribuer
c'est vrai ce que via les collectivités
c'est un début de solution à cette
pénurie de masques qui marquent notre
pays depuis le départ ce retard pris est
tellement difficile à rattraper
je pense que cette pénurie de masques va
cesser mais est-ce qu'elle aura vraiment
cessé le 11 mai rien n'est moins sûr
d'ailleurs je ne le crois pas ce sera un
peu plus tard
et d'ailleurs le gouvernement adapte au
fur et à mesure ça sans le dire sa
stratégie au manque de moyens et aux
différentes pénurie de masques de tests
en particulier risque pénurie de
médicaments bref on est quand même dans
une gestion qui a toujours un peu un
temps de retard donc le premier ministre
essaye de faire au mieux mais avec des
contraintes qui sont extrêmement fortes
et sur lequel ils passent parfois assez
vite
un mot sur lequel sur un territoire sur
lequel il ya beaucoup de contraintes ce
territoire c'est le vôtre celui de paris
paris en zone rouge en zone rouge
certainement pour un certain temps qui a
pour autant une place très importante
d'un point de vue économique et où on
comprend qu'il faille reprendre
l'activité mais aussi à la question
notamment des transports collectifs
métro et rer c'est un casse-tête dans la
capitale de reprendre l'activité pour le
11 mai pour vous
c'est difficile ça montre d'ailleurs
qu'il faut aborder la question
au delà des départements cette question
de la métropole dans son ensemble et
toute façon cette pandémie est un défi
énorme pour toutes les grandes
métropoles du monde
c'est vrai pour londres c'est vrai pour
new york c'est vrai pour tokyo c'est
vrai pour paris cette question des
transports ben là aussi elle nécessite
absolument qu'il y ait des masques pour
tous les voyageurs elle nécessite que
les collectivités locales les communes
la région l'état la ratp puissent
travailler ensemble
le temps est très court d'ici le 11 mai
donc de distribution de masques
notamment dans les gares d'ile-de-france
mobilité c'est un tout à fait mais
est-ce qu'on a la garantie que ce sera
le cas pour le 11 mai ses landes corps
voilà il nous reste quelques jours pour
répondre à cette question c'est
absolument indispensable
la pandémie est en train de reculer en
ile de france elle peut reprendre très
vite et très fort il faut tout faire
pour l'éviter
donc évidemment sur les questions
scolaires et sur les questions de
transports publics c'est un enjeu énorme
surtout si nous ne voulons pas reprendre
évidemment une circulation automobile
infernal un retour de la position il
faut pas non plus qui est de retour en
arrière de ce point de vue là donc cédé
en effet des enjeux très difficile avec
un temps très court qui est qui est
devant nous un défi de taille merci
beaucoup et merci à vous d'avoir répondu
à mes questions j'y faisais allusion à
l'instant edouard philippe
le premier ministre a est également
intervenu dans l'hémicycle tout à
l'heure pour est bien précisé le nombre
d'annoncés sur la doctrine de l'état en
matière de masques l'accompagnement des
collectivités pour l'acquisition de
masques par l'état on écoute le premier
ministre tout à l'heure je crois que il
les plus justes de d'étendre ce
dispositif à toutes les commandes de
masques passé depuis que le président de
la république a évoqué la date du 11 mai
parce que dès lors que le président l'un
public évoque le 13 avril la date du 11
mai il me semble que toutes les
commandes qui ont été passées dans le
par les collectivités tahrir par les
collectivités territoriales
pardon à partir du 13 avril doivent
bénéficier du même du même
accompagnement et de la manui même
encouragements je dirais que celui que
l'état propose proposé hier par ma voix
hier à la tribune
donc voilà les choses sont claires
s'agissant des collégiens l'état
fournira et s'agissant de l'ensemble des
commandes passées par les collectivités
territoriales pour équiper population de
masquer l'état accompagnera pour les
commandes qui sont passés à compter du
13 avril et je suis à présent avec ronan
dantec ronan dantec vous posiez bien
cette question à laquelle et d'un
philippe n'a pas complètement répondu
puisqu'il a répondu à la question qu'il
souhaitait sur la question des masques
néanmoins ce que vous vous réjouissez de
ce que dit le premier ministre un
accompagnement des collectivités pour la
l'inquisition de masques cela depuis le
13 avril à hauteur de 50%
c'est un motif de satisfaction oui
évidemment je crois que on est dans un
moment avec la rencontre avec des
associations d'élus et le premier
ministre matin il faut absolument
renforcer la collaboration la
coopération entre le bloc communal et
l'état c'est comme ça qu'on réussira
résoudre cette crise effectivement je
crois qu'il était important que le
premier ministre soit précis sur le fait
que toutes les commandes depuis le 13
avril seraient pris en charge à 50% par
un par l'état et je crois qu'on a devant
nous une autre opération très importante
entre le bloc communal les collectivités
et l'état c'est sur ces fameuses
brigades de suivi des cas diagnostiqués
de coronavirus moi je suis extrêmement
attentif à ce point j'ai mis en place un
groupe de soutien scientifique en en
loire atlantique pour justement concédé
les collectivités territoriales
oui mais ça va être un point absolument
centrale
si on veut résoudre cette crise pouvoir
isoler très rapidement non seulement les
gens porteurs diagnostiqués mais aussi
ceux qui potentiellement serait déjà
contaminants donc je crois qu'il faut
renforcer cette coopération
mais néanmoins le premier ministre a
aussi répondu à ma question qui était
une question très précise parce que
c'était un petit peu ambigu dans sa
présentation à l'assemblée hier qui est
que l'état fournira bien à l'ensemble
des collégiens
les masques nécessaire je rappelle que
pour un collégien qui a beaucoup de
transport public et qui a une journée
complète au collège ça veut dire quatre
masques dans la journée donc là je crois
que le premier ministre ait
effectivement a répondu assez
précisément à amay questions sur ce
point parce que sinon ça pourrait être
une charge assez élevé pour les familles
plutôt un motif de satisfaction donc
pour vous rendre dantec
oui voilà je crois que on a joué nos
drôles qui est ces questions d'actualité
dans la crise que nous vivons peuvent
pas être un lieu de posture et
polémiques comme on en a peut-être un
peu l'habitude des fois je crois
qu'effectivement on a besoin de
questions d'actualité qui permettent de
préciser des points qui resté ambigu et
là sur deux points précis
effectivement le edouard philippe nous a
répondu merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
répondu à mes questions les questions
vous vous posiez d'ailleurs et bien sûr
l'inégalité pour les français d'accès
aux masques en fonction est bien de leur
revenu c'est aussi cette question là que
j'ai posées à la secrétaire d'état tout
à l'heure agnès pannier rue nash et
écouter tout de suite sa réponse lors
nous travaillons avec les associations
de défense des consommateurs je les ai
d'ailleurs réuni vendredi dernier nous
avons passé deux heures ensemble
justement pour leur demander de jouer ce
rôle de vigie ce rôle d' alerte pour
défendre les consommateurs
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation nous
avons plusieurs circuits de distribution
des circuits de distribution qui sont
portées par l'état je veux d'abord
rassurer les français
lorsqu ils enverront leurs enfants à
l'école il y aura des masques
disponibles dans le primaire ils ne sont
pas obligatoires mais ils seront
disponibles pour leurs enfants
il y aura des masques disponibles au
collège et là ils seront obligatoires
donc les parents jusqu'à la fin de
l'année scolaire n'auront pas à équiper
leurs enfants de masques
deuxième chose importante pour 5 pour
les personnes vers un exploit sera
fournie par ces masques dans l'état et
moi je suis en train d'aller coller que
j'entraîne d'acheminer dans les écoles
et les collèges des volumes de masques
textile et de masques à usage unique
parce que probablement qu'au début les
masques à usage unique seront plus
simple entaille pédiatrique
donc c'est un point que nous prenons en
charge
deuxième élément nous mettons à
disposition des préfets et des mères
chaque semaine 5 millions de masques
pour les personnes vulnérables 5
millions de masques lavables 20 fois ses
100 millions d'équivalents usage
si vous comparez ça des masques
chirurgicaux par exemple donc c'est
considérable
cela également sera gratuit troisième
chose
effectivement nous avons travaillé main
dans la main avec la grande distribution
pour qu'il prévoit d'acheter des masques
et de les mettre à disposition des
français le plus vite possible ce sera
d'abord des masques à usage unique car
ce qu' ils sont fabriqués de longue date
donc plus facile à approvisionner par
rapport aux délais de réouverture des
commerces puis des masques textile et
pour les masques textile nous avons
travaillé sur un prix de 2 à 3 euros 2 à
3 euros pour des masses qui sont
lavables de 5 à 30 fois ça fait un prix
l usage qui nous est indiqué par la
grande distribution de 10 à 30 centimes
lusage ça ne s'est pas également
important est ce que vous prévoyez un
accompagnement vous avez il est annoncé
un accompagnement pour les collectivités
mais peut-être aussi un accompagnement
pour les personnes les plus modestes
pour qui même de 2,3 euros représente un
coût c'est ce que j'ai indiqué c'est les
5 millions masque chaque semaine pour
les personnes les plus vulnérables 5000
m aux basques vulnérables sens
financièrement d'accord plus
effectivement ça c'est la santé qui
établira la liste des pathologies où les
conditions d'accès à ces masques les
personnes vulnérables
cette fois ci d'un point de vue
sanitaire auront accès à des masques
enfin vinci avec le conseil qui va bien
lorsqu'elles présentent des pathologies
qui les expose au regard du coc vide et
donc là aussi ce sont des masses qui
seront mis à leur disposition
donc vous voyez on a anticipé ces
situations les personnes amenées à
budget modeste les personnes qui
envoient leurs enfants à l'école et bien
sûr je le rappelle les employeurs qui
n'ont pas la capacité
à assurer en permanence la distanciation
sociales dans leurs entreprises doivent
équiper leurs salariés est ce que vous
le dites
aujourd'hui l objectif avec ce
déconfinement hier le premier ministre a
parlé d' éviter l'écroulement de la
france c'est avant tout une reprise
économique aujourd'hui l'enjeu que nous
avons c'est de refaire démarrer la
machine avec des conditions sanitaires
irréprochable ces conditions sanitaires
il faut les respecter strictement rien
ne serait pire que de ne pas respecter
la distanciation sociale et de devoir
constater une reprise du virus et de
devoir tout arrêter à nouveau et on est
capable de le faire dans les entreprises
où le sait il ya des entreprises
françaises qui exercent notamment en
chine et qui nous font des retours sur
le fait qu'elles n'ont pas eu de cas pas
eu de cas de coronavirus dans leur
équipe et on parle d' équipe de
plusieurs milliers de personnes depuis
leur reprise
donc ça c'est un récit intéressant mais
ça veut dire aussi de notre part
collectivement de la discipline le
déconfinement ce n'est pas le retour à
la vie convivial qu'on a connu
malheureusement vous souhaiterez tous
mais ça ne sera pas possible dans
l'immédiat
voilà pour ces précisions apportées tout
à l'heure par la secrétaire d'état
espagnole nash et notamment sur la
question des masques le travail
parlementaire le suivi des travaux
parlementaires continuent sur public
sénat tout de suite et bien on va
prendre la direction de l'audition de
brune poirson la secrétaire d'état qui a
été auditionné ce matin en
visioconférence par la commission du
développement durable au coeur de cette
audition à la loi sur l'économie
circulaire elle prévoit notamment
l'interdiction des emballages en
plastique à usage unique d'ici 2040 et
bien brune poirson l'a redit ce matin il
entrera en vigueur aux dates prévues
tout de suite
voyez cette audition peut-être pour
commencer quelques constats maintenant
que nous sommes dans une crise sanitaire
depuis au moins un mois et demi alors au
départ au moment du début de cette crise
sanitaire on peut pas nier que dans les
premiers jours les activités de gestion
et traitement des déchets qu'on était
déstabilisés c'est ça pour le secteur
des déchets c'était aussi le cas dans
beaucoup d'autres secteurs économiques
français
je pense par exemple dans le cas
spécifique des déchets au maintien de la
collecte sélective au fonctionnement des
centres de tri à celui des déchetteries
mais la mobilisation du gouvernement des
collectivités locales et les élus locaux
ainsi que l'ensemble des problèmes des
professionnels du secteur a été je crois
là aussi relativement relativement mais
remarquait mais l'a conduit en retour à
une activité adaptée au maintien des
activités prioritaires relativement
rapidement et aujourd'hui à moins de
deux semaines du 11 mai on peut tirer
donc plusieurs constats d'abord constat
fondamentalement important c'est que la
salubrité publique a été assurée
notre système de gestion des déchets a
tenu imaginez dans quelles situations
dangereuses y était nous aurions été si
en pleine crise sanitaire il y avait
encore une qu'en plus ça se passe ce
serait super poser un problème de
salubrité publique
donc malgré la crise la collecte et le
traitement des déchets ménagers ceux des
risques infectieux notamment celui qui
ont aidé pour eux qui sont produits par
la profession médicale à savoir les
dasri ou encore les déchets des secteurs
économiques essentielles à la nation
tous étaient assurés on vous serez par
exemple très tôt assuré que les
conditions sanitaires suffisantes soient
mises en oeuvre pour les professionnels
du secteur avec par exemple